Good morning, John.
I don't know.
Say it with me.
Good god! It is liberating! I am a towering
mountain of ignorance! I DON'T KNOW!
Why is a plumber named Mario? Mario, the most
well-known video game character in existence?
I don't know.
Why are guitars shaped like this?
[Hank makes weird noise]
Why is Iggy Azalea popular?
Good lord, I have no idea.
I think that I know a lot of things, though
when I play Pub Trivia with my friends, I'm
surprisingly unhelpful.
But, the vast majority of things, VAAAAST
majority, I don't know.
And not just because of the sheer number of
things, but also the number of things that
affect those things.
We live in an age where we are taught to believe
that everything has a reason.
And so we observe the world, we see what happened,
and then we define the thing that happened
as the reason the thing happened.
Like we say, Harry Potter's popular because,
uh, it took place in a school and it was well-written
and we had a deep and unknown desire for silly
wizards.
Which is the exact same thing as saying, "Harry
Potter's popular because it's Harry Potter."
And then we think we solved it, and then when
other books about wizards and schools that
are well-written come out, we're like well,
it's not Harry Potter.
Yeah, so it doesn't have all the attributes
of Harry Potter, so it's not as popular as
Harry Potter. We're really good at this.
Now, I'm glad that we have the desire to understand
the world. That results in all sorts of great
stuff.
We wanna know everything. We're humans. We're
curious. And maybe it's our culture, maybe
it's just humanity.
But, I think a lot of the time we end up mixing
up thinking something with knowing something.
Suddenly, it's kinda expected that everyone
in the world has an opinion on how to solve
the Syrian Civil War and how to create more
jobs in the United States and "What are the
effects of cell phone use on the youth of
today?"
Now, I know that I don't know, but somehow
everyone else seems to know.
They all know differently from each other,
but they all seem to know.
When you look at all deeply at this, you realize
that people aren't basing their opinions on
what they think is the best course of action
or the actual best explanation for it. They're
basing it on their values, and that's fine.
It's what values are for, and values are great.
But it might be a little silly to think that
you've discovered the best possible course
of action just because you figured out a way
to turn your values into executable vision.
Now, these guesses are useful, tremendously
useful. Weeeeeeee-eeeeee! [laughs]
We convert our amalgamated opinions into,
like, reality.
That's the terrifying beauty of culture, and
more specifically democracy.
But, they are just guesses.
No one knows the correct course of action.
We will never take it because there are too
many options.
What I'm saying is nobody's opinions are correct.
In the world.
And yet, it's impossible not to tie your opinions
to your concept of self.
And often, people tie those things so closely
together that they begin defending their guesses
as if they're defending their very lives.
In a way, they are.
This is why it can be so impossible to talk
about certain topics with certain people.
They've tied those suppositions to themselves
so tightly with knots of narrative and constructed
reality and values that there's just no untying
it.
And maybe, unsurprisingly, in those situations
the best course of action is just to be friends.
Maybe even ask them about that thing that
they've created because, to them, as it is
to all of us, it's immensely valuable.
The world as we perceive it, as we've built
it inside of ourselves, is a lie that we tell
to ourselves, not out of deception, but out
of necessity. We have no other choice. We
simply cannot understand the world as it is.
And so, we construct, and it's a useful construction.
And it allows us to do many amazing things,
but sometimes I just have to tell myself the
thing that is definitely true, the truest
things I can say, which is that I don't know.
I don't know. I don't know. John, I'll see
you on Tuesday.
And often people tie those things so closely
together thathehet-
So closely together that their...
So closely together that that it is...
So closely together that they depi... PPPpllblbll.
So closely together that the, that the, the,
that the, the, that the, that the the, that
they, the that da, the, that, the they the
that the they, that, they they that the da
the the they.